we're gonna walk through this solution
and I'm just going to highlight a few
important pointers as we go along okay
the first thing you'll notice is
everyone was pretty happy identifying
what the question was much to my relief
I have broken up the question even
there's an A and a B I've broken up the
question into three parts because a
itself has two halves right you go find
the stationary points and then going to
work out what kind of station points are
they and they're quite distinct
processes right so you can see I've
color-coded them and my letters along
the left-hand side I've color-coded
appropriately so first we'll do the
stationary points they will find out
what kind they are then we'll look at
these points of inflection which we kind
of introduced and talked about earlier
all right now the very first thing that
I do is I find the derivative now a few
people said find the coordinates and
they made that their very first thing I
sort of get what you were getting at
because I asked you to locate stationary
points so you're working is well let's
find the quality of the stationary
points the reason I haven't put that
first is I can't find coordinates which
is an x and y value until I find the x
values and I can't find the x values
until I've got a derivative so that's
why you can see this connective tissue
is really important and I hope that my
reasoning will explain to you why I've
got it in the order that I do okay so
then I start to say okay stationary
points exist when and this is where I
then solve for the first derivative
being equal to zero and no earlier okay
you then get your pair of X values and
with those X values
you now know assuredly if the first
derivative zero these are definitely
stationary points and so the next thing
that I do is find out where they are
okay find the coordinates of the
stationary points it's worth mentioning
coordinates can happen later or earlier
but business seems the most natural way
to find them so I take each of my X
values I substitute them into the
original function and that gives me a Y
value I've located the stationary points
but I haven't determined their nature so
that's why I haven't got a concluding
statement just yet this is when I
transition into the second part of Part
A determine nature right over there on
the top left-hand corner okay now before
I proceed to tell you about the rest of
the order
look at em right what method have I
chosen to determine the nature because
more than one what have I chosen second
derivative right I didn't have to use
the secondary I could use the first
review which I already have up above
this is what it would look like if I did
that you didn't have this working
because that's not the way that I chose
to do it in the piece of paper I gave
you can anyone tell me why I didn't use
the first derivative I could have but
why didn't I
bhishan okay so number one it's like I
learn how to do the second derivative it
alright and you guys just learn how to
do it that is the first piece but even
if that wasn't the case if this question
just got given to me I would solve it
using the second derivative if you've
got your flow chart there it gives you a
bit of a clue no I yeah this fraction is
some function that I began with it was
it's a cubic or something right it's a
cubic of some kind it's not a fraction I
don't need the question room when I'm
differentiating in fact it's very easy
to arrive at this second derivative so
if it's easy just go for it man okay so
that's what I've gone ahead and done but
if you wanted to deal with the first
video that's what it would look like two
tables of values for two different
stationary points okay once I've got my
second movie and this is actually really
important so I want to highlight this
for you you might need to write this
down as separate to your working because
it's not on there okay let's just have a
look at the first stationary point X is
negative one I substitute that into the
second derivative and I get this value
second derivative is equal to negative
seven okay now please put some colors or
some big boxes or highlight in some way
where you can see on the right-hand side
because we haven't talked about in much
detail before so you should have your
pen in your hand right now to include
this right when you draw a conclusion
about the value of the second derivative
you need some words to talk about what's
going on here right the second
derivative is negative so that tells you
about the concavity and the king cavity
tells you what kind of stationary point
it is okay now lots of students rush to
be able to say oh I know what this is
it's a maximum right under no
circumstances should you do this because
you're leaving out a critical piece of
you the logic of your argument right
you're like why is it a maximum
on what grounds and the answer is it's
because of this statement we make about
concavity that's a really important
point the second derivative tells you
about concavity and then you draw a
conclusion about the stationary point
from that so you I'm gonna show you
later on there are some words you cut
out of this but these are not words you
can cut out they are absolutely
essential and then I draw my conclusion
so this is part a finishing up I know
where the stationary points are I don't
know what kind they are so here is my
conclusion right here at the bottom
where I tie everything up in an 8 bar
located determine nature finish ok then
we move on to Part B which you can see
in orange now again I'm gonna ask you to
highlight something for me which I
didn't write on there or something I did
write actually if you look at the part 8
question I said stationary points exist
when the first tribute is equal to zero
okay and I send that with no ifs or buts
they just always do you find the first
derivative is zero you have a stationary
point but I wonder if you noticed if
anyone knows this teeny tiny word that
appears in the working for Part B which
is this guy here points and inflection
may exist when the second derivative is
equal to zero which is the next line can
anyone remind me why is it that I have
to include it's actually very important
I have to include this word may any
takers it could be naught or it could be
yeah yeah me me bad English that's
impossible okay so despite the the
questionable grammar this is exactly
right finding the second derivative
being equal to zero does not guarantee
that there's a point of inflection okay
it might be that we do' y equals x to
the power 4 the second derivative equals
zero at the origin but it's not a point
of inflection it looks like this if
you're a call roughly okay so that's why
I say May and that is also why when you
go further down you have to check where
there it actually is and that's why I
verify by checking on either side of
what I think is the point of inflection
okay so I think there's a point of
inflection at x equals 2 and 1/2 and so
I check just to the left at 2 just to
the right at 3 and I see that there is a
change in
just here and here goes from negative to
positive okay so it's concave down then
it's concave up if there's a change in
concavity that's a point of inflection
no some people have said hey look at
this working here part or working J
right those coordinates couldn't I do
them like earlier on right because I
don't need to know the whether this is a
point inflection to find this point
can anyone suggest to me why it might be
a better idea to wait until you've
actually verified before you go ahead
and work out the coordinates any
suggestions it feeds directly off what
we're just talking about with a with
this guy up here have a think
why would I find the coordinates later
rather than earlier good question
why would I after determining okay
second derivative is zero I think it's a
point of inflection why would I not rush
to just find out the coordinates why do
I go through this table business which
is quite time-consuming
hmm well no I try boy what do you want
your thoughts okay okay so this is this
is the crucial point right and they make
sure I repeat it so you're caught it
because I suspect some of you didn't
when you go to this point here right
here okay you think you've got a point
of inflection but it may not be so
therefore I'm not going to find the
coordinates of something that might not
even be something I'm interested in I
want to check that it actually is what I
think it is before I find its
coordinates cuz that's all work that may
not be required so why might it okay no
no this is a this is a really this is
the question it's why I picked out this
example okay points of inflection may
exist when the second derivative is
equal to zero but there are cases where
the second derivative is zero but you
don't have a point of inflection okay
the the classic example I gave you guys
and we ran through at last lesson so
I'll come back and help you revise that
if you need extra power for it's not the
only one it's just the simplest one
where
you get the secondary of being is equal
to zero but you don't up you end up
getting a change in concavity there's no
point of inflection so it's like kind of
maybe better check question okay so if
we got say for example on both sides
zero and then there's what you think is
a point inflection in n 0 again what
that tells you is it's a lot concave up
it's not concave down there's just local
cavity you're like going along a section
it's not concave anywhere that's telling
you that section is a straight line so
that also is not a point of inflection
either okay it might be X to the 4 but X
to the 4 in fact does change its value
of can carry it just goes positive and
then 0 and then positive again so it's
concave up the hallways what I'm trying
to say at this point you're pretty much
at the end this is where I conclude I've
found the coordinates and therefore I
can say since I already tested for the
change in concavity
there's my conclusion right down there
at the bottom with my coordinates and my
confirmation yes it's there ok now just
one last thing I'm going to show you
before I am set you know we're just on
some exercises for last like 15 minutes
is I'm just gonna you can put your pens
down now for a second I'm just gonna
show you the same working but with as
few words as possible the reason why I'm
showing you that is to show you why not
to do this
okay um here's the same working okay now
if I take out all of those phrases and
connective tissue this is what it looks
like and hundreds and thousands of
students around the state do you they're
working exactly like this because
they're like I want to do this as fast
as possible words take a long time to
write I'm just not gonna write them okay
the reason why I really dislike doing
this you can see there are some words
that are not optional like you have to
use words here if you don't use these
words your answer is just wrong because
it just doesn't include the details that
you mean the reason why this is still
problematic is if you have a look
through here there's all this kind of
parallel working that it's not clear on
what it means for example x equals
negative 1 and x equals 6 right I do it
here and then I do it again down here
there's x equals negative 1 and x equals
6 all over again
why am I doing this all over in in
repeat if you like and the reason is I'm
working out completely different things
each time I'm working out coordinates
and then I'm determining nature okay now
that the word it's not clear at all
what's going on the worst case scenario
is you write something like this which
like I said most people do this
statement here with no introduction this
statement here is just wrong the
derivative of this function is not zero
the duty of this function is this guy
here it changes value all the time but
I'm finding where it's equal to zero
which is at a couple of particular spots
namely these stationary points okay so
that's why I've gone to all the effort
to provide you all that language I hope
you make sure you actually get that in
your books because this is an exemplary
answer so the kind of thing you would
find in the specimen solutions for the
HSC okay